everybody welcome to the live mission
Conan Q&A yeah guys why are you why are
you yelling I'm trying to get the energy
up it's live energy up but we're sitting
in what looks like it's very depressing
airport lounge and you're yelling
there's no reason to yell I'm so sorry
Wow please welcome Conan O'Brien Lori
Kyle Martin and Bryan Kylie and we are
gonna be taking your questions on
periscope and YouTube today about the
mission Conan show which aired on Monday
just fantastic and in case you didn't
know our whole show went to the Al Udeid
Air Base in Qatar upon invitation from
the first lady yeah and we did a show
from there so come you want to kind of
explain how this all came about did you
just get a phone call from Michelle
Obama's office or how did this happen we
want a contest shocking we we were
invited by the first lady the first
lady's office called my office my
assistant screwed up the call I never
got it Jeff Ross he taking a preacher's
assistant save the day but then she
asked if I would accompany her and put
on a show for the troops at the Al Udeid
base in the Middle East in Qatar
obviously you say yes in that situation
I want to do I did a USO tour I think in
2005 and I remembered at a time that was
just me thinking I love this this was a
great experience but what I learned is
next time I go I'd like to bring more
really give them a huge show so with
that in mind I asked two of my great
writers to come with me who are also
really funny stand-ups they're not here
right now
Brian Kylie and Lori kill Martin I said
would you guys come with me and help me
write my set up top but also also do a
set yourself so that we have some some
you know more meat on the bone and they
said yes which was great and then John
Mulaney heard that I was going through
back channels and contacted the White
House I don't know why yeah so yeah
Michelle Obama she picked it right up
and obviously that's great
and then we asked Grace Potter who's a
friend of the show in an amazing just an
amazing singer and performer incredibly
sexy but so we had and then we brought
Jim Aveeno and we went and we did a show
and the show I remember thinking it felt
really good it's about the best audience
he'll ever play for because they're so
excited
they were extremely pumped and first
lady introduced me I did the show I
think she left immediately after she
introduced me so that she wouldn't have
to hear and be present when I started a
war and we laughed then we did the show
then we stayed on the air force base and
the next day we spent the whole day
shooting pieces for the show which end
up that's where I get attacked by a dog
if you haven't seen it you should check
it out I'm mauled by a dog sort of like
Leonardo DiCaprio in the bear and we
have a lot of adventures and that was
really fun and it all came together as a
show yeah yeah and you can watch that
show at Team Coco comm slash mission
Conan and we're gonna take some
questions from YouTube how long were we
at the base guys why don't you take over
epitaph Laurie all right how long how
long how long was the actual
trip I feel like 534 we left on
Halloween night yes and we came back on
the fourth thank yes so very quick and
and basically the show is shot in
basically that's one day almost the
entire show there's two days yeah it was
also like a full day there in a full day
back yeah yeah the traveling there's a
there's an incredible amount of time I
think it's 18 hours from well for me it
was from watch maybe less but from LA
it's 18 hours to get to just get to
Dubai yeah and so yeah and and you guys
went a little ahead of you you went a
few hours ahead of me yeah because I was
flying with the first yeah we got we got
there basically a day before to scout
out everything and then and then yeah
then Conan arrived and we kind of took
kind of walked around and and figured
out what we were gonna do for for the
actual show how did you guys kind of
prepare Kylie how did you prepare for
this kind of experience I well I did
stand-up for about 25 years
now you quit Laurie and Brian are both
two people that you can pretty much wake
up at three of them water on maybe the
morning and say give me 30 minutes what
do you want it or not
and Laurie you've done us before during
the Gulf War II always American what was
like on the base I mean there are a lot
of cliches when people come back from a
trip like this and they say Oh our brave
men and women and sometimes it can sound
like people were just sort of spouting
this rhetoric like they go into a trance
and just say the politically correct
things I can say that it is very I don't
want to say it's just not just like
life-affirming but I I felt so good
about meeting all these men and women
they are really funny they're excited
they seem like they're they're there to
do a job they take it very seriously but
there I was shocked at how much because
there were times when I'd see them out
of uniform when they're like headed to
the showers or taking a jog or something
and they're wearing flip-flops and
wraparound glasses and they just look
like I don't they look like 22 year old
so that you would see in Westwood you
would see you know in any college town
and they were incredibly friendly a nice
I think I think I took more selfies in a
24-hour period I may have broken some
kind of record
because everybody wants a selfie and
yeah you don't fly all the way there but
I'm going to Afghanistan tomorrow to
risk my life and I think every one of
them took ten pictures I guess or
something you know of these happens
sometimes is that dew line up and you'd
be like a hundred and I take selfies
with all of them and then once or twice
someone would seem kind of familiar I
think I got a selfie with you already
and you'd be like I got you twice
so from YouTube says your specials are
killing it for Mission Conan to Star
Wars all of it all have been great you
see a future where specials and remotes
play more central parts are there more
upcoming travel shows have it gets it
done no we have to say I absolutely love
we've been doing this for a long time
I'm constantly meeting you know 60-year
old women who say I grew up watching you
reminds me that I've for a long time and
so what's nice is when it has felt like
in the last two years there has been
this with these travel shows and these
specials and going to comic-con yeah I
feel like a kid again I feel like we are
getting to be funny in different ways
it's invigorating it's so exciting
and so and I would love to just die I
said that the beginning of this year
let's double down whatever we did last
year was double down and try and and do
almost twice as much travel so we do
have plans to go places I think we're
going to Tampa Florida just to see what
that song
to the future periscope periscope is
asking how did you manage not to get
sunburned and actually we have a great
everybody got these hats here there
here's a picture Conan at John Mulaney
as you can see in our high-tech photo
there everyone it was the whole thing
that what are they called the P X or the
DX that we went shopping at there's a
place where you can go on on the base on
the base yeah they're actually two there
were two of them and you can buy pretty
much anything you can imagine that you
could get at a Costco Walmart you can
get there and it says Al Udeid base on
it and it has I did the deed in Aldie I
bought so many of those Speedos it is
like a Walmart because they sell guns
there I were a very powerful sunblock
military-grade sunblock you have to
worry about yeah and you have to worry
about so it's not just me I mean yes I
am the kid from powder woman skeleton
but yeah I have to say I mean it was
kind of amazing to see you know
everybody come together because we had
such a short time there and that the
conditions were crazy I mean you spoke a
little bit about this actually in the
live show on on the episode but
everything there is beige and it's all
awful it's a very yes they say it's it's
the best description I'm sure a lot of
you I mean I'm sure everybody's seen the
movie the Martian if you haven't spoiler
alert he goes tomorrow Larry Larry so
that's comedy I've seen
but but it really did if you've watched
the movie the Martian that is exactly
what it's like to to be there and
they're in and less read but more just
this kind of beige and everything is
this sort of Sandy Bay right and it's
just you think it'd be so easy for
someone to put up like a fake Christmas
tree or something nothing there's
nothing and you there's a part in the
special where I I find some tiny little
shrubs that are a little bit green range
of age and I'm freaking out because it
was the first sign I had seen and you
think why can't they just occasionally
paint like a little purple door trim or
something no I guess that's I mean I
guess they have their reasons right no
animals I mean I didn't see any what
there's not a scorpion nothing that you
would expect to see even in hot weather
you know it was just it is a pretty yeah
you get the sense that that absolutely
nothing would choose to live there yes
that's why you realize when you look at
the base you see these massive trucks
that are just bringing in water yeah
anyway and also the people who are the
most the most like highest status on the
base are not the four-star generals this
is no joke
it's there's this team of guys that
fixes the air conditioners maintain the
air conditioners and they are treated
like gods there because we were
fortunate when we were there it was
relatively moderate meaning it was in
the 90s yeah I think yeah I think the
temperature is getting to the 130s
sometimes and if the air conditioning
isn't working people will perish so and
and having good air conditioning is so
important there plus those guys there on
the tarmac there they're fueling the
planes yeah so it's even hotter there
yeah yeah that summer I can't imagine
and you still have to go to work if the
air conditioner doesn't work yeah I
would just refuse to come in someone was
saying
I think sergeant Mac one of the people
who was assigned to us they had to leave
their building because the air
conditioning broke so they literally had
to vacate the building to go to another
building because it was so they were in
a pizza oven basic all right crazy yeah
Laurie what was one thing that surprised
you the most aside from the Bayesian is
about this trip or being on the air base
and with these people or just a
highlight right hmm well it was a shock
that that the soldiers all seemed to
work 12-hour shifts seven days a week
for six months - yeah yeah yeah and it's
just the same thing every single day so
I think that's probably another reason
they were so excited to see the show is
that it just broke up what must be
incredible man I mean the Bayesian is's
monotony did the whole thing it just it
must be really hard there was a really
weird moment where we arrived we I think
I arrived on him we arrived on a Monday
we got there and it was Monday night in
alle deed and then slept there on the
base woke up Tuesday morning we all went
to the mess hall and you get your tray
and you you go through you know to get
your food in this giant place that makes
breakfast and lunch and dinner and we
went through and then we sat down and I
noticed all these monitors were playing
Monday Night Football and I said to this
soldiers at my table
oh that's cool they record Monday Night
Football so you guys can watch it in the
morning and they looked at me and they
said no that's life so it was just I
mean yeah that's so I'm sure a lot of
people right now are watching like it
was such a weird thing to be so far away
from the United States that Monday Night
Football is happening live at like nine
o'clock in the morning you're sitting
there eating eggs and watching it they
are living it is like they're living on
another planet definitely yeah
absolutely
and I was talking you know some of them
they go a year year and a half about
seeing their families or whatever and I
I mentioned it to my wife and kids and
they didn't
[Laughter]
I think it's time for just just one more
question this is by the scariest moment
for us but Conan was getting attacked by
the dog the scariest thing you've ever
done no no wasn't I mean I I'm fortunate
I've grew up with dogs I love dogs even
a German Shepherd attack dog first of
all I'm I was aware that I was wearing
this suit that was going to protect me
yes yes and and I had facial protection
because you got to protect I'm very
fortunate I like animals and I like
being physical so I that kind of stuff I
don't find when I do the physical things
on the show or on the remotes I
they look scarier than they are the one
thing I will tell you is they told me
once the dog takes you down remains
still because I think the dog is trained
if you keep struggling that's when it
will pull your carotid artery out of you
so I you've never seen me more still in
my life when the dog tackled me and I
went down I just went completely inert
and the guys got the dog off me really
quickly but other than that I I didn't
find that you know frightening I've
taken the shuttle from Boston to New
York and it's turbulent and that's when
I get but a dog trained to rip my throat
out for some reason doesn't scare me I
will say one thing I've never our
executive producer Jeff Ross is the
coolest cucumber ever and I've never
seen him scared ever until I
you were running and you're like I'm
gonna do the ops of course in your rent
and you got into that pipe I just saw
them go for a second his eyes went big
and I was like oh my god you know like
what if he doesn't get out of the pipe
or something and shimmy through another
right right he was just worried about
his next paycheck all right well guys
thank you so much for joining us thank
you
- Brian Kylie Laurie cool Martin of
course Conan O'Brien follow these two
you should do this on it we should do a
regular show like this yeah yeah I want
to meet here regularly you make I'll
give you each $1500 a year yeah of
course I'll be making thank you to
youtube and periscope and please watch
mission Conan team koco.com slash
mission Conan you can also see
behind-the-scenes videos and photos and
all sorts of good stuff and my deepest
sensual secret seriously it's all in
there it's hidden ya little hidden
easter egg by the way easter egg is one
of my sexual anyway if you go to those
shows I'd look at them and watch the
whole show and really pay attention a
little sexual secrets a little puzzle
for the Internet to figure out thank you
guys for joining us and make sure to
watch our show tonight eleven on TBS
we'll see you guys next time
you